jo und beim Bundesvision Song Contest
haben wir jetzt Stanfour das klingt
eigentlich nach vor ich sehe jetzt zwei
wie kommt das
die Sofa sind die große noch hier
deswegen sind wir zu zweit
das stimmt nicht doch stimmt finde ich
also wir müssen größere Ecken ausruhen
ihr hattet noch alle da wir haben noch
eine Probe alle die den Rest gefeiert
das ist leider dann passiert manchmal na
gut wie viel waren das vorher es wir
waren nämlich ich habe sieben gezählt
glaube ich noch ein bisschen jetzt
deutlich
wir haben mitgefeatured Kino Sound und
ähm also übernahmen und Nummern bei uns
zu sprechen weil wir können uns nächste
Woche treffen dann sind noch mehr Leute
oder weniger auf der Bühne deswegen
würde ich das ähm hast du noch eine
Frage vielleicht okay ich will trotzdem
was ist denn weg was ist denn der Kern
der Band oder der Truppe seid ihr beiden
das kann man das so sagen ja also wir
sind zum ersten gewesen und ähm deswegen
sind wir auch jetzt hier
wie ist das gekommen also nicht dass er
hier seid sondern man also hier schon
aber beim Bundeswehr Song Contest
ähnlich wie im Saarland sehr gut weil es
hatte ältere Bruder und ich finde dafür
auch die ganze Frage beantworten also
ich kann ihn nicht mal nach hinten
zurücklegen müssen ja es ist ein
komische Geschichte für eine
englischsprachige Band hier aufzutreten
weil es ja in Deutschland Musik Contest
ist aber wir haben irgendwie es
geschafft uns hier rein zu schummeln
ohne dass jemand uns rausgeschmissen hat
bis jetzt vielleicht merken sie dass wir
englische Chorus zu singen aber wir
gucken mal 50% deutsch sein ja wir haben
das hingekriegt wir haben grob geschätzt
das musst Du nachher dann noch mal
nachzählen wie gesagt zwischendurch
immer ja ja und das ist auch Deutsch
genau die Masse genau also wir
wiederholen einfach drei Worte die ganze
Zeit so ein paar Linien so ein bisschen
ist okay okay und wie soll der Eindruck
bis jetzt hier Probe habt ihr hinter
euch
ja große Bühne große Halle alle geben
sich große Mühe sieht gut aus also ich
kann mir vorstellen es ist ein schönes
Event wird fühlt man sich nicht ein
bisschen einsam auf so einer riesen
Bühne ich habe das gerade gesehen es ist
der Hammer also wir haben wie gesagt das
Glück dass wir ein paar mehr oder ist da
sind aber ich glaube ich kann man schon
vorstellen dass die Leute die da alleine
stehen
auf jeden Fall beeindruckend ist dann
die die die ähm szenarieder also das ist
auch eine wahnsinnig große Leinwand
hinter uns also dass wir noch nie
gesehen also das sieht echt überraschend
gut aus alles aber trotzdem nicht dass
der dass man so ein bisschen Atemnot
dann kriegt wenn man damit in der Mitte
steht ich glaube die haben dann
wahrscheinlich wenn die Halle voll ist
momentan ist immer noch so damit
beschäftigt irgendwie seine ganzen
Detail Sounds und so zu finden und ich
glaube der Moment wo man dann halt eben
realisiert das ist halt eben große Bühne
so eine große Sache ist dann dann wenn
dann das Publikum da ist zufrieden mit
dem Sound im Moment ja sehr zufrieden ja
war echt gut ja ich meine es geht nicht
so schnell also man macht das ja zweimal
durch und so aber es war wirklich guter
Sound und sind zuversichtlich okay ihr
seid zuversichtlich welche Chancen
rechnet ihr euch eigentlich so aus gibt
es Wetten in den Garderoben nicht also
ich habe noch überhaupt also ich
überraschenderweise sprechen die Bands
untereinander überhaupt nicht über diese
Dinge also wer gewinnt ich weiß nicht
ich glaube dass die die meisten das eher
so als als eine Plattform sehen einfach
sich zu präsentieren vielleicht neuen
Song zu präsentieren und ähm und auf die
Stefan habe schon vorhin meinte in der
Pressekonferenz es gibt ja ganz wenig
Chance im deutschen Fernsehen wo es
überhaupt noch Musik halt eben im großen
Maße gibt und das ist halt einer dieser
dieser Sendung und da freut man sich
einfach dabei zu sein und machen zu
dürfen und ich ich ich also ich habe
meine Tipps also die ähm der der Favorit
ist ich glaube die sind ja auch
offensichtlich okay
er ist schon öfter mal bei uns genannt
worden die Leute wissen wovon hier
sprechen trotzdem was wir machen wir
fordern alle Leute auf die das sehen
dieses Video zu favorisieren thumbs ab
außerdem und natürlich so oft zu sehen
wie es nur möglich ist wenn ihr Stanford
sensationell findet und ähm was hättet
ihr denn gerne von den Leuten die das
hier sehen wir würden natürlich wir
müssen natürlich
großartig wenn ihr für uns anrufen
würdet und ansonsten wenn er nicht
anruft kauft unsere CD
ja man kann weitermachen komm zu
Konzerten wir haben auch kleidungsmittel
die man tragen kann
entspannt wir freuen uns wenn der Abend
vorbei ist hier und die Affen schon bald
losgeht und wir sind eher olympisch
geprägt heute abend okay das war das
Interview mit den beiden und dann noch
mehr auf der Bühne die wegen der
aftershop-party sind